what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here
it's wednesday the 11th of may
greetings from podcast villas uncle
joey's joint
is brought to you by on it listen
whether it's room tech
alpha brain shroom tech sports shrooms
tech immune
the protein bites on it has it all the
cmt
oil on it has it all you understand me
i love them i've been with them for 10
years i go on alpha brain
[__] cycles like people go on steroid
cycles
i'm always on the shroom tech sport when
i go to the gym
to give me that little extra [__]
boost if you don't like pills they got
alpha brain in a powder form you can put
it in your shaker i mean i love
everything about on it and so should you
right now they're having
i think it's a tail end of the
semi-annual sale so you won't need a
[__] code
they just slashing [__] prices on
kettlebells
club bats everything i can only just
help you with the vitamins and the min
and the supplements
but they're having a semi-annual sale on
everything there's no code needed the
prices are that low
do me a favor go to honor.com right now
and if they're not having the sale
press and code church or joey and get 10
off and it's delivered right to your
house the joint is also brought to you
by
my all-time favorite c b d lion listen
if you're looking for cbd maybe you
don't even know what cbd is
do yourself a favor go to cbdline.com
right now
and read up on the third-party lab
results this is not
some gasoline attendant selling you this
this is not some guy with an ipad
selling you this at a gas station
or some [__] liquor store this is
uncle joey telling you
to go to cbd line and read read about
cbn
cby cbd and the benefits and
how it can help you whether it's pain
irritability
you know anxiety whatever you may have
find out how cbd line can help you
within the back balls
the [__] weed they have now they have
joints they have cream if you need it
cbd lion has it but it all starts for
you
go to cbdline.com right now read
read please read read what's available
to you
you're going to be [__] amazed
pressing code joey at church
get 20 off and it's delivered right to
your house no more [__] headaches for
you
so go to cbdlion.com right now
and knock yourself the [__] out the
joint is ready to [__] go
this [__] candling light i think they
sold me a trick candle at that place
i love you [__] enjoy
welcome to uncle joey's joint
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday
may 11th welcome to uncle joey's joint
it's a beautiful [__] day to be alive
you know it's been a weird uh week but
not really hopefully
the nfts get put up today on patreon so
that's a [__] good thing
uh nft is like electronic art a lot of
people are into them
i don't know much about them i know that
i was getting tortured for a few weeks
if i was gonna do nfts and
my agent called with an nft guy so i
said [__] let's put it together
a little something for the [__]
patreon people you know you got to take
care of your people
and i want to talk to you people about
some about i wanted to talk to you
people about something today that's been
uh on my mind lately i was talking to my
neighbor the other day and he was
talking to me about this period of time
that we've gone through you know
and it was weird like i was [__] up
like everybody else
march april may june july i had my ups
and my
downs you know how to make decisions but
a decision that came to me july 12th the
day that they said they weren't going to
reopen the schools
i had to make a decision on what to do
with my daughter
and i was like [__] it she's going to
school so i got to move i didn't know
where i was going to move
but there was another decision i made on
july 12th
and this is goes back to journaling and
it goes back to all these things that i
do
to be a better me and that's checking
yourself from time to time
you have to be honest enough to look at
yourself in the mirror and go
what are the areas i need [__] help
with like what the [__] is going on with
my life
like i didn't want to move to new jersey
and bring luggage
you know i was on rogan one time and he
asked me about how i got
funny like i went from being a mediocre
comic
to a good comic in 98 and i explained to
him that we
lose luggage as we as we get older you
learn how to deal with personal
conflicts
and you eliminate them and it makes you
better
whether it's addictions you know i
became better as i was giving things up
you know i always knew i wasn't going to
give up a reefer
and when i was doing coke i was
committed to cocaine i mean i'm not
going to lie to nobody
i was committed to cocaine because i
knew i wasn't going to quit
but i was also committed to quitting
when it came time to quit
and i got better from it so as a human
being you have to look at yourself from
time to time and go
i'm a [__] piece of [__] like i did
i'm slipping in all these areas
and nothing was more evident to me was
when
i did something i [__] i'm totally
against
and that's watching myself right before
we moved one day i go
if i start a podcast what do i want the
next podcast to be if i do start that
and i turned on the church and i saw
myself with a [__] white t-shirt on
and i realized that right there i had
been slipping
you're not supposed to wear [__]
t-shirts as a t-shirt
right there like my mind right there
like just those little things
made me new made me know that my mind
wasn't right at that time
i don't know if it was the [__] the
edibles i was taking
the [__] amount of reefer i was
taking what i was going through the
podcast
going on the road i don't know what had
happened but i knew one thing that i had
let myself go in a lot of the little
areas
if you look at me today i could tell you
one thing i gave up butter
i only eat one piece of toast for
breakfast wheat toast
and i put butter on it and and i put
butter on mashed potato
i put butter on corn i eliminated butter
from my life
so i lost 30 [__] pounds that's what
you mean to tell me because i live and i
was eating that much butter i wasn't
but there were all these things that i
had to stop doing
you know listen i got problems
i'm always going to be doing some type
of [__] something
so instead of doing the edibles in the
daytime i moved them tonight to sleep
that was a big step right there me not
doing edibles at all from the daytime
you guys know me from all the way in
[__] september
i wanted to improve on my sleep i wanted
my body to get stronger
you know i had the [__] surgery out
of nowhere i decided on the surgery in
december
you know like a bionic [__] man my
goal every day during this pandemic
was to come out of it i knew it was
eventually going to end
but what position was i going to be in
when it ended i know right now there's
people that are drinking three times the
amount they were drinking
before the pandemic because they started
drinking earlier now
they started drinking at one o'clock 12
o'clock 11 o'clock
because that day was gone they collected
unemployment they got no [__] job
they got no screen to look at i'm not
mad at you i'm not hating on anybody
i'm just talking about the truth here so
i wanted to come out of this
a lot better than i went into it you
know i'm saying like that was my
goal once i realized that i was [__]
up for so long
you know quitting the reefer was not my
plan at all that
that was not my plan i could show you
the [__] change manifesto i wrote
and reefer was not in my plan what was
in my plan was to cut down a little bit
i felt that i was smoking a little too
much i felt that i was smoking in the
daytime
and i felt that i was carrying over into
my family life
and that's why i had a [__] stop like
right now i would love to smoke a joint
it's my [__] basement
weed is legal in jersey but i'm
disrespecting my daughter this is her
house also
three people live in this house this is
not just my house
three people live in this house and i
had to make a constant
i had to make a decision about that i
didn't want to smoke anymore in the
house
you know you got to go outside down the
road there's a little [__] parking
lot that you could smoke your brains out
there's no cops there nobody will say
nothing to you
it's just a short drive up and if the
cops come i could walk home
you know but these are all little
decisions that i made to be a
better person i improved on my
journaling i worked on me being a better
husband
because i tell you what this pandemic
when i found out
that we were going to be stuck in a
house you know
instead of becoming her enemy i became
her friend
so out of this out of this [__]
pandemic i became a way better husband
a way better [__] father you know i
got sick and tired of calling on
saturday mornings
and my daughter's with her friends and
my wife is with her friends and my
friends
and i'm in some [__] hotel room in
[__] kansas city
playing tittle winks you know that's not
what i want to do so when i do go on the
road
it's going to probably be one-offs you
know i'll do a friday theater somewhere
a thursday theater somewhere it's not
going to be
i can't keep [__] up my saturdays
from my daughter
during the week it's one thing during
the week she's got school
and you know my my rule of my house has
always been
monday through friday do whatever the
[__] you want
saturday and sunday you got a commitment
to your [__] family you know so
that's been my whole thing since the
beginning
eventually i have a plan and my plan is
this
to quit smoking for so long that
when i start smoking again i'll just
start smoking at night
and i'll get so far i'm going to go back
to 14 milligram weed
i'm going to try to get 40 14 weeds
and start from there and work myself up
that's how you do it
a little poke that's how you do it you
get your tolerance back i did this in 89
90 when i was in a halfway house i would
roll a joint and just take one little
hit
and get [__] blasted
i would get [__] blasted
so this is what my goal is again so for
you [__]
top heavy duty guys uncle joey's just
taking a breather
unbeknow is to me and unbeknownst to you
we have a little zoom guest today i know
you guys some of you don't like
it some of you don't give a [__] and
somebody is like joey we love what
you're doing
and i appreciate it this is the only way
to do it now and until we move this is
the
this is the new standard a lot of people
don't want to do face to face so what do
you want me to [__] tell you
i'm here face to face with you
[__] twice a week that's all you
[__] need
but without further ado my brother mr
hari shafir
what's going on [__] sorry dude
yeah all right
what the [__] is that behind you what
are you [__] ground zero or some [__]
yeah i'm rebuilding it so people can
knock it down again
what's happening brother how are you i'm
great it's [__] summertime in new
york
how long have you been back for two and
a half weeks
three weeks thanks so far it's
overwhelming i got called an [__] my
second day here
by who because i was making it right on
red i forgot i've been in
different countries i'm not going to
ride on red [__] [__] it was
it was three lanes over and i'm like all
right i'm sorry calm down
my dog would cut off somebody jogging
she's like fire [__] jogging [__]
good morning it's a different [__]
city isn't it
oh my god six months made a [__]
difference that pandemic [__] killed
that new york city
i was there three weeks ago i was in
shock
yeah i had to go into daytime and i was
blown the [__] away there was nobody
there
oh no times square is [__] empty
that's why all the homeless had to move
down to the [__] east village
there's nobody there nobody in the city
[__]
you know 11 in the morning i left the
[__] north bergen at
10 15 and i got to 40th street between
5th and 6th avenue at 10
30. zero traffic zero traffic
i smoked the number there was nobody on
the street
yeah you know the chipotle was open i
went in there to get like a
a mix uh you know i do the beans and
rice sometimes that's your first mistake
you're in new york city you're getting
chipotle how
dare you nothing else open there was
nothing else on the block trust me
i'm not a chipotle guy at all but if i'm
in a pinch the black beans and white
rice
aren't that bad i get the veggies i
don't eat the meat or nothing
i ate it the last time i was in new york
because i was staying on 33rd and third
and there was nothing open at night in
that area so
that's why i moved out of that [__]
hotel because i had to go to chipotle
one night and it was good
it was good that night and i'm like the
black beans and rice are good then i
went to california
i went to the movies one day and i go
i'll eat the chipotle i had to throw the
[__] thing away it was
so goddamn bad but if i'm in a pension
place and there's and there's no bodegas
open or nothing like that
i gotta hit [__] yeah i gotta hit
[__] chipotle if
i'm in a pinch trust me i don't wanna do
it either but
you gotta do what you gotta [__] do
what else is going on with you you doing
standing you look good yeah
man i had to change it all up i had to
change my life
for the knee i wanted to lose weight
just for personal reasons
just i want to lose weight i want to
change my diet up
i changed the lifting up like i told you
i haven't smoked pot in a week
just because i would never even imagine
that joey diaz couldn't smoke pot i
wouldn't even do a 420 [__] podcast
because it was like
i'm lying to him if i do a 420 i haven't
eaten an edible
in the daytime since october
dude one of my favorite memories is you
at the improv in in in uh hollywood
and you told the crowd you're like yeah
i'd stop smoking weed and they all was
like
what they're like oh i still vape and do
edibles
and they were like ow all right
i think we misunderstood yeah no i still
take my edibles to go to sleep at night
last night my [__] i laid down my
heart was beating up a storm i'm like
what the [__] was in this edible
i took like three 200 milligram capsules
and i [__] took like the tea
and two gummies
killing me why i didn't get used to it
six months i haven't had any regular
edibles and the weed they have is all
dipped in acid
so it's [__] it's not as strong but
it's more psychedelic
well so i i was just here and it's like
ecuador the weed is dipped in acid
a lot of it yeah real acid there yeah
they love acid they'll just give it a
little sprinkle
and when you get [__] high what do
you see what kind of devil do you see
when you smoke a joke like lines i was i
was smoking
in the amazon and i was staring out it's
a sunset all the birds coming out
and i just see these lines in the
[__] and i'm like what the [__] kind
of weed is this i didn't figure it out
for about a month and somebody told me
some locals like oh yeah
a lot of people dip there we need an
acid here probably what you got
i mean i was just like visuals on on
weed and i'm like
maybe it's just i'm like no i'm a
[__] pothead there's no weed this is
gonna be stronger than i've smoked
this didn't make any sense until they
hit me with that acid info
that's crazy you missed that i'm not
complaining
yeah you're a world really man
you're a world [__] traveler i can't
i give you that props
right off the bat you don't give a [__]
where you go
china you wanted to go to cuba everybody
wants to go to [__] cuba
they wouldn't let us in you know there
were less than 100 covert cases there
they [__] did it nobody talks about
cuba when it comes to covid
one person they [__] nailed it they
had the medication
they don't need no [__] stinking
vaccine they got a pill that you're home
within three [__] hours
in cuba nobody got [__] covered they
wouldn't let nobody into the island
if you had it you got shot that's it no
spreading
we're just shooting you what do you want
a cigarette or a cigar
there's just something there exactly
they did something there you told me
about like it's a thousand dollar ticket
if you're caught without your math
1500 fine without it and by the way
they're a lot poorer than here so that
1500 is like 10 000
to here and it's people just like i'm
not doing it they'll throw you in jail
that's what they did in the galapagos
same [__] they pulled full lockdown
at 4 00 p.m you can't be outside and so
what happened like one of our friends
did like what happened like they were
arrested
let out the next day and they said if we
catch you again it's gonna be a week
so it was like people just stopped
[__] with it there was a
place in mexico where the narcos were
shooting people
if you didn't for being out if you
didn't have a [__] mask
you would that's [__] crazy yeah
that's crazy
are you doing stand up again
you have to stand on tuesday nights
you're doing
a little [__] show how are you
thrilled
i feel terrible i don't know what the
[__] i'm doing anymore i mean i have so
i'm okay it's not that if i can riff and
make fun of a crowd member
that's okay what what's problem is
there's three stages of stand up right
now there's whatever i built
in the last few months there's last
summer
stuff you know with the election and
black lives matter and [__] uh
who knows what you know covet and then
there's stuff i was doing before
i feel like a fraud doing the [__] from
16 months ago i feel like what the
[__] wrong with you couldn't write
anything
you're still doing that i feel like an
[__] doing that even though if it's
good material i'm just like not yet i
can't do it yet i'll get back to it but
not yet
what about the material from the special
done
finished that tour so that's it that
you're like me you don't want to use
that material
and that's holding your back after a
while i'll tell you what i didn't get on
stage for seven months
i got on stage like in september and it
felt good for about four minutes
yeah yeah it felt good i did ten minutes
and it felt good for four minutes
and then i started doing spots at uncle
vinnie's
who i loved the club i loved dino i love
everything
about that place and the more i went
down there hari
yeah i felt the more a fraud
why because just like what you said the
material was old
like i would sit at the computer here
and look at the old material and try to
write new material
and i would get down there and i'd
forget the new material
and i'd have to hit him with old
material and i'd
i'd feel like a [__] loser at the end
of the night
i kept doing it and doing it and going
to uncle vinnie's and doing it
and i really wasn't happy with the work
i was doing i didn't
yeah especially over the summer you had
like yeah this massive election you had
black lives matter you had covert you
had this all this new stuff and you're
still doing
not you but i mean if someone's still
doing like traffic's crazy on 42nd huh
and you're like what the [__]
the [__] are you talking about yeah no i
wasn't in the moment
i didn't feel myself being in the moment
yeah
and then i had the knee surgery and i
took a month off and i started doing
wednesdays again
and then i tore my it band
it still [__] hurts in my cash no
what'd you do
what were you doing duncan you want me
to tell you the truth trying to do
a [__] windmill getting on stage
i didn't know what i was doing and when
i went to get on stage i got on stage
with the right leg
and i got to tell you something as soon
as i stepped it was like a 12 inch step
and i didn't realize it i felt the whole
[__] bone
in my leg rattle i felt everything
rattling and i'm on stage i got a pain
pill in my pocket
that i cannot take well i'm trying to do
material with this [__] pain
that is gripping through my body and i
went home
and when i got home i went up the stairs
my wife was gone that weekend
and when i walked up the stairs i hurt
my leg again
and i had to put ice on it and just lay
down and it was shaking i didn't know
what happened the next day was a little
swollen
and like later that week i went to the
doctor and they told me you
they did an x-ray and they go you ripped
your right t-muscle
so they did like a little incision and
put some stuff in there was
painless it was evasive but you know
what it never really healed yet
the knee is healed dude i i i see people
being rusty
forgetting what to do on stage i've
never heard of someone forgetting how to
get onto the stage
when i got onto the stage i got on with
my right foot i forgot all about the
surgery
you know you're doing stand-up you're
excited you're not you're not real
you're not thinking about it
now i look at every [__] step i take
i'm worse than [__] sting
i look at every [__] step i take
every step i take
i gotta look at my [__] feet but that
night i [__] up my leg i went to the
doctor
and she told me i tore it and she goes
just stay off it so i'm gonna catch 22.
because you got to go to the gym and
ride the bike to maneuver your knee
and you got to use the it muscle so the
more i build it i rip it the following
week again with the exercise
so it's just [__] killing me like i
have i'm not well i'm lying to you it's
not killing me right now
i know what you're doing and i go ah
like i stepped wrong like yesterday i
went to my daughter's softball practice
and when i got up off the bleachers one
time i put my leg
up too far and i could feel what are we
even cheating i don't [__]
what am i chilling i just sit there with
my mouth [__] you can't say nothing
because they'll throw you out of the
league last you got to bring the old
school in you got to bring the old
school cheering like you did in saturday
night fever where you were like don't
let that stick strike you out
like this crazy [__] like oh my
god last week the coach got into an
argument with the ump
and my old joe diaz came in and i'm like
hump you suck
and one of the parents like don't say
that they won't let you on the field you
won't be allowed in the field no more
you can't say that
you just ran the [__] away and the coach
said something to me
two nights ago at practice he goes hey
the reason why i was mad at that ump i
[__] emailed people afterward and
they're gonna they told me the hump was
wrong so the hump had to apologize to me
so i kind of felt shitty that i told the
yump he sucked because he did suck
you know well whatever don't suck then
by the way that thing you told me you
know listen
we've watched a lot of movies during
this pandemic i mean
i've watched thousands of [__] movies
to the point where i can't watch another
[__] movie
but i did watch saturday night you
re-watched it fever
way before you said that joke to me the
other day
oh my god dead dad called dario what's
going on he goes nothing i watched
cyanide fever last night
i didn't know there was so much rape in
the movie i go oh my god
that's right that's a big rapey movie
all you remember is a dance contest
they just glanced over the rapes yeah no
the rape was terrible you know who the
chick is
they got raped she's
pat parisi's wife on the sopranos no way
he watched the sopranos the mother pat
parisi
his wife they only showed her like
seasons why are you crying when i do it
you didn't cry when he was there
yeah that is the most disturbing [__]
movie in the world all those 70 creepy
cocaine movies
that beginning last night i watched
papillon
wow how to get off the island that's a
good one a long one too
wow i sat here until 11 o'clock just
[__] mesmerized trying to figure out
who directed this movie
because it was like a stanley kubrick
type movie i don't know i got so [__]
yeah they're trying to get off the
island the whole time and the rich the
rich
who is the rich guy was the guy from the
graduate the [__] jew dustin hoffman
yeah yeah he was tremendous the rich
they bump into julio from sanford and
son when they get to honduras
and he [__] runs them out i mean the
movie is [__] tremendous
but back to sinai live i don't think i
think the 70s
i think i saw first of all there's never
been a rape scene that i've seen that i
don't feel [__]
i don't feel good you feel creepy
death wish is the worst rape scene
saturday night fever is another terrible
rape scene the worst rape scene is the
movie with jodie foster
thank you the accused when she's in the
bar in boston
that was tough difficult any time you
just wanted to end just like come on
you're like why don't you do it [__]
watch this [__] this is
death hunt's rape scene destroyed me
when i was a kid
because i saw it in the movie theater oh
the the rape scene and death wish with
jeff goldblum
and you know i think it's jeff goldblum
and the first one
is [__] disturbing and i saw it as a
kid
and i remember thinking about my mother
being at the bar going
holy [__] this could happen to my mother
like i'm gonna [__] kill somebody if
this happens like this
is not good so all those seventies
movies that have
that's my worst whenever i ha whenever
in my head like it's like if if uh
i don't know let's say renaissance and
his wife are over and his wife's not
gonna walk the dog real quick
anybody that i know that it's like they
go outside and it goes in my head and
start
going like oh i wonder if as soon as i
start thinking rape i'm just
i just might have to go please just
someone just murder them instead of that
just like yeah no i don't i'm not big on
another [__]
and those 70 movies they they're a
little bit on the graphic
side yes this has been on the last four
nights
and i didn't watch it i'm like i've seen
it too much yeah
i got it prepared last time i saw the
[__] exorcist i did mushrooms by
mistake
and went home i had like some mushrooms
at the office
and lee kept telling me that the
mushrooms tasted like [__]
and that they grow and [__] how can i
eat them and i'm like [__]
everybody eats [__] mushrooms you're
the only person
ever that's complained about them i've
been involved with mushrooms since 1983
in colorado
and not one person has ever said to me
they taste like [__] you know there's
people that say they don't taste good
and they make it into a tea
[__] off shut the [__] up it's good for
you that's why i got
so [__] pissed at him one night that
i took the biggest stem in the [__]
bag
and i go lee don't taste like [__] i
just chewed the whole [__] thing
all the way down swallowed it and then
after the podcast i went to pee and the
bathroom was purple
and i'm like i'm [__] i'm [__] up
i got in the car i ran home made a big
mistake and
it was 10 to 11 when i got home i go
perfect i'll watch eyewitness news and
calm down a little bit and go to bed at
midnight
and i scrolled you know how you scroll
to see what's coming on the exorcist was
coming on
it was 10 to eleven i go [__] i watch
the exorcist
big mistake yeah big mistake it's too
real that movie's too real
i lasted maybe 22 minutes
yeah and i had to turn it off and run
into the bedroom like a little girl and
just put my head under the pillow
then i realized i couldn't fall asleep
because i didn't have the sleep apnea
mascot
i'm like what the [__] is going on with
my world this is terrible
were you legitimately scared of a horror
movie i watched cujo when i was still
scared of dogs and tried to walk home
three minutes uh and my friend nathan
butler said
there was a dog just barking and i was
like [__] this i went i took it 45
minutes
around the neighborhood so i just have
to pass that dog i gotta tell you
something you just reminded me of a
[__] tremendous movie i haven't
watched
cujo in 20 years yeah i played a movie
since
another one real it's real so it's like
[__] this could happen you know what's
really good
what the book i read the book when i was
locked up
oh it's a cool book oh
[Music]
very scary i think i had a cover of a
of uh something on the cover what is it
a dog a lion
what are they scared of dog probably
does a dog yeah it's a big thing
there was a dog on the cover [__]
scary as [__]
that book [__] me up that's what
turned me out to stephen king
that's how i fell in love with stephen
king that's one of his greatest [__]
books
that's what i liked him he's like that
version of stephen king is like the old
wwf with hulk hogan and andre the giant
and all them and then how it changed so
stephen king back then is cujo
carey you know uh uh monkey tails or
whatever the one with the monkey on the
cover is the short stories it's just
like those and then they did like the
watchtower or whatever the watcher and
that was like a later thing i was
looking for that book i'm
that book is do a read which one
on writing by stephen king i don't know
where the [__] it is
it's over there somewhere yeah but let's
do a read that's a great book the story
about carrie
how he wrote a he was a janitor in
vermont at the time
it's a [__] janitor so for you people
who are jealous at home you got hope
you got that's right steve either
goodwill hunting hunting or stephen king
yeah he was a janitor and he [__] was
writing part-time he didn't know where
to start you know like any other [__]
schmuck
and he was writing a story about a girl
who could move stuff
with her mind telepathically and he
wrote the beginning where
she got her period and she didn't want
it and he hugged it up
and he looked at herself he looked at
himself and he goes what the [__] am i
writing
and he threw it away and his wife walked
past
looked in the garbage took the script
out read it and said what the [__] did
you throw this away for
finish this and that's carrie wow
sometimes wives are [__] life savers
they'll tell you exactly what the [__]
we don't listen to them because we're
jerk offs but his wife
told him to take it out and finish that
[__] script you know what made that
movie so good too that book's so good is
all the [__] christian undertones to
it because her mom [__] space sack in
that movie
i think it was her beautiful in that
movie yeah but it was like you get under
the stairs and it was like it's weird
like
you're being held up by christianity
while your wild other side is coming out
just in this
rageful and they hit it with that pig's
blood
bad move that was a bad [__] that was
a pre a prequel to like when people knew
jiu jitsu but they didn't look tough
they said people like we could pick on
carrie she can't do [__] little scrawny
[__]
what are you gonna do like [__] that
world
you know that's another movie that had a
little bit of travolta in it
that was from travolta blew up walter
was huge on saturday i know i signed
that live
welcome home welcome back carter
so he was huge they lied to you they
told you travolta was in the movie and
when you
went to the movie the travolta was only
like in two scenes
what was he when he was one of the jocks
right he's one of the guys that he was a
he
busted the balls he was the one chick's
boyfriend
that's right at the end he dies when
she's walking down the road
and he's driving towards her and he goes
i'm going to hit her and he swerves and
she
gives her the t yeah and then he [__]
goes off the cliff and [__]
he was only in it for maybe one or two
scenes they lied to you
you went down there to see john travolta
little did they tell you he had three
[__] lines in the movie
so he was on fire as ironic fever he was
so
[__] electric he was got i always
heard uh tarantino talking about him
like bringing him out for uh for pulp
fiction
and he goes he was one of the biggest
movie stars in terms of movie stars not
in terms of like
draw but just in terms of how he took up
his screen and i was like uh you know
i'll take the word for it
you know but then you see him and you're
like god damn you're so
brash and [__] oh i would lick that
guy's [__] in a movie like that and
if
you know if he took me back there he'd
be like look maria oh or whatever i
can't do the impression
whatever he wants not anymore now you
can't now he can't buy him now you got
to get in line
now you got to [__] compete with him
to give him a massage and [__] like that
boy john
he loves those young masseuses his wife
died i mean he had
he's had a rough go of it his son passed
so
my heart goes out to the travolta family
i mean he's made you know the last
people beat up on him lately because of
his movie choices
bro the guy's wife died the guy's son
died you know
god knows where his [__] mind is
actually they want these guys to be at
the top of their game forever
they'd rather them just die at 45. you
see de niro
same [__] where people are like what is
this what is it you know and it's like
dude
he's an old man he ain't a 26 year old
anymore like [__] it he's an old man
you're lucky he's doing anything
you know what the [__] match premiere he
fell asleep
he was right in front of us we were
sitting next to each other he was right
in front of us
and he's passed the [__] out it was past
his bedtime
eight o'clock and de niro's already in
[__] bed that's right you went to the
premiere with me
his head was got a little hat on
remember he had a little hat on
yeah he was all the way back he was
[__] snoring
he wasn't out a little he was that's how
you can tell when you're in a bad movie
when you pass out of your own [__]
movie
once i saw he was asleep i'm like this
is a bad [__] movie we're not going
to make any [__] money with this
movie the movie
the only good thing the only good thing
is we left afterwards everyone's taking
pictures of the red carpet and big [__]
was there and i was there
my phone is off out of respect for the
movie and i take a picture like it's
gotta go on it took three minutes to go
on these [__] iphones and now he was
like hurry up and i'm like i'm trying to
try i got another picture
remember we're walking down the stairs
that's how we bumped into puss we were
walking down the stairs
all of us it was like 200 people and i'm
like what are you doing here he's like
what the [__] are you doing here
finally everybody tells me i look like
you i can't believe it's you
everyone's like who's this joey diaz you
look like joey dance i'm like what the
[__] is your idea
it was so cool it was so cool seeing you
guys face to face it was like
wow it was it was like [__] macho man
and hulk hogan turning around it was
like
like just two powerhouses meeting each
other so what are your plans now what do
you want to do now what's your next move
what are you thinking go back in the row
build a new hour
you know i i start road road with my
leftover [__] and get on
june 11th and 12th in hartford and then
some gigs in july
and then september hard
also though dude listen i like to go up
on stage
i'll go up non-stop but the travel
that's gonna cut down you know
i like doing stand-up but i don't i can
do it for 25 here
as much as i can do it for two grand you
know on a flight
so it's like i'm doing some gigs
but i'm taking august off to go get
drunk with my friends the whole i love
last summer in new york
they do walk tales they [__] put a
capri-sun pouch full of margarita and
said
enjoy and you just walk around he's
right next to a cop who's where's
the street and they're like that way sir
they're all scared of us now
now you can smoke weed right in front of
cops wheat is legal in new york now for
black people too
it's [__] great and you smoke wheat
and drink in the streets and i'm like
i'm doing that again i told all my
friends take august off if you know
what's good for you
we're gonna have a great time go to
jones beach have a [__] blast
throw up in the street at [__] 6 p.m
like a man so
i'm gonna do a lot more of that hanging
out enjoy myself and then september i'll
hit it hard again
what do you think about the state of
stand up for right now for you what do
you think
i i think i'm going to have more fun
with it again because last whole tour i
was trying to build
a specific hour about judaism and
religion in general
and now it's like those shackles come
off i'm going to have fun again i
remember
i'm doing the shows with these young
comics run and they're still
creative they're still like i'm gonna
try a character today or i'm gonna do
this today and it's like oh yeah
just fun for fun sake so like
do more of that do more like hey come
meet me to stay and let's do a little
sketch instead of doing stand up
let's have a [__] good time you know
come in the cellar let's just [__]
around let's pretend i'm gonna tell you
remember remember domino's what was this
razor or arrow i forgot what to do it
was a brand new open mic he would get
flustered all the time
he'd be like hey you guys ever take the
bus sometimes and somebody goes
yeah he goes
and you have to start over hey you guys
ever take the bus uh sometimes
it was just like it's so fun i don't
know that's what i want to do i want to
have fun again
i want to have fun with travel i'm
combining everything i got two weeks in
washington state
spokane and tacoma and i think september
so o'neill's going to open for me matt
edgar's going over for me adam amiga is
going to come meet me
pc's going to come meet me we go camping
in between
it's a four-hour drive so we're going to
drive two hours go camping for four days
and then [__] do the other
shows i'm having fun that's that's what
i'm planning for stand up
uh you got you got to hold on to the
good parts of this [__] cobin you
know
some people are so terrible but i'm like
you know all these businesses
first of all a lot of those businesses
[__] sucked let's all be honest with
ourselves
when that guy delivered food cold late
at night you're like i hope you got a
business
well guess what you got your [__]
wish so you got to hold on to the good
parts and that's what i'm trying to do
hold on to the good parts of kovan
you know i want everybody over 70 is
dead already i want this [__] to be over
with
i see a light at the end of the tunnel
like everybody else sees
you know um i don't know what i'm gonna
do with stand-up yet
you know i just had another call today
for a book a publisher
i've got like six chapters written i got
uh
jimmy florentine's cousin uh niece she's
a writer she's
already an author she's published so
i've been working i've been working with
her since january
so um i think that if we
continue to do this the book will be out
by [__] the book will be finished by
november and out by february
maybe march the latest because they want
an audio book also with the company's
meeting with so i got my hands full with
that
you know the podcast is struggling i
don't give a [__]
i just struggling i just like the idea
of coming out and talking
giving my thoughts out whether they like
it or not you know we know the window
you know you know the podcast window you
know the the entertainment world
and you have to take advantage of it
when the iron is hot
and sometimes the iron gets cold but you
still got to do your [__] thing
regardless
every day you gotta push and that's what
i'm doing you know
i'm starting to think the [__] the
interview podcast has kind of run its
course
yeah i think the interview everybody's
got one so you're not uncovering
anybody's story you're just hearing the
same stories
over and over again difference people
start getting like autopiloty a little
bit but there's
it's just like it's it's kind of mac
either the morning zoo type podcast
like uh legion of skanks or your mom's
house or [__] like that just like fun
for fun sake
even that it's like we didn't get into
the radio hosts we were just doing it
for a little bit
we're all stand-ups so it's just like
whatever once you're making enough
to get by may as well have fun you know
for me i just wanted to get out of this
funk the pandemic
affected me weird like
gotta stop reading the news dude i gave
up in [__] july thank you
for telling me you know now but i
stopped last july before i moved but the
damage was already done
sure you know the damage is already done
i figured out that
i couldn't watch the news anymore i
haven't watched it at all i don't i
nothing nothing did i care less about
politics i could care less about
anything else
i knew that you know you got to sit
distance yourself you got to weigh your
mask
that's what i knew so that's what i did
you know the only news you need is a
weather report did you get vaccinated
yeah i got my one i got my next one like
in a week or so yeah i got vaccinated
regardless of what people said listen
you're going to need that card for a
while to get into places they're going
to break your [__] you can't get into
the yankee stadium without the card so
i'm doing it plus
i heard there's a side effect that turns
your dick bigger than it normally is
well whatever the [__] the side effect
is
i really don't give a [__] i just uh
wanted to get this over with because i
got sick and tired of getting the emails
every three days
you ate lunch at a place the waitress
was contaminated no way
really
the cashier had it and then it started
at the comedy club where i was going i
was like you know what
that's it i can't take this you know i
had i was taking so many tests i had the
guy like on a salary
for [__] two months the guy told me
you come here so much yeah
because i was going there so much the
guy's like listen joey i would just work
with you
you know just give me like [__] idiot
test or whatever you pull out into your
90s coke
nah that shit's gone there's nothing one
pocket in there
no because remember i had the nose
surgery uh-huh
no surgery and that's when they found
the hidden treasures and the biggest
things
you know what my doctor's name was that
did the surgery dr line
that's a lie that was his name i'm like
you're my perfect [__] doctor just
draw out dr live and he knew it too
after the surgery he's like man you had
some weird stuff in there like i know
27 years of doing blow you're going to
find harper his cousin you're going to
find something in that [__] schnoz
look at the size of it now then i lost
weight on my face
it's even bigger than ever i look like
an angry jew now and [__]
that's right i always give me [__]
having a big nose what about diaz i
brought a couple of looks
yeah this weight loss is uh it's been
great listen i
i'm having a great time hari i gotta be
out listen if you want me to tell you
i was telling mike i missed the good
people from l.a i missed the jerry
roaches and the steve simone
i wrote yeah and the people that just
had no malice in their heart
i miss i i don't miss the desperation
i don't miss talking to folks desperate
there
i don't miss that chatter you know a
couple weeks ago a friend of mine called
me
and she's like i think he would work
well with these people they manage a lot
of podcast people
the 10 minute call was brutal all right
listen to him just listening to the guy
i finally just hit
[__] end and i text the guy and i
said the phone call went down
they kept texting me back what are we
going to meet i don't want to meet i
don't want to see nobody
you should hear them talking about the
hollywood way of talking just that
hollywood way of talking
i'm done like i've detoxed now to the
point where
i look at comics and i could tell what
the [__] that problem was i could tell
that dad molested them
if their uncle stuck a finger up their
ass if they got beat up
like now when i see a comic i'm like oh
this goes back to this
like i'm so far away from that realm
of l.a i got nothing against anybody i
still love the comedians i loved i loved
it's just that l.a we both got
soured normal good people got sour
and they felt like they had to like do
this oh i gotta go talk to that guy he's
a big guy
but this guy's your friend this guy's a
fellow [__] yankee fan
you'd rather talk to this guy but that
guy's on a show like that's not you're
not that guy you're not that person
who would choose that over that and yet
everyone felt like they had to it got
sick
it got really sick you know you remember
when we first got to the store in 97 90.
it was
yeah 99 for me it was a [__] rat hole
nobody cared about anybody there's
nobody's doing [__]
nothing but everybody you remember those
older guys that hung out
yeah sure i remember even looking at
those guys and going
i don't want to become one of them
i don't want to become one of them yeah
if there's anything i want out of comedy
is i want to do comedy
but i don't want to be one of those guys
that's holding on to this place
for [__] the last hurrah and listen
that wasn't my
situation that wasn't my case i was very
lucky at 58 that i walked out of the
comedy store i didn't walk out i didn't
crawl out on my knees i walked out like
a [__] man i'm very proud of that
but at the same time i put my 30 years
in they
they the comedy store was always a place
for young comics
to grow and they told me when i started
there the reason to get into the comedy
store is to eventually get out of the
comedy store
to get out of the car and then it became
more popular and people stayed and
stayed the state there was no like
reforestation supposed to go 10 15 years
get a sitcom get out somebody knew was
two years in now he's seven years in now
they're great
and they get a sitcom seven years later
somebody else comes up it was always
that cycle
people stayed but man i i i argue with
people on this a lot
to me that the heyday of the comedy
store is not when you have lineups of
like
silverman david spade rogan fitzsimmons
uh uh the guy from texas uh uh jeffrey
it's not that
the heyday was a bunch of nobodies and
then let's see if we can see some
[__] older comic [__] somebody in
the back
you know we have a little [__]
makeshift casino where the bartenders
aren't even [__] working they're all
they're gambling
it's [__] dark degenerate [__] you
might try to [__] a waitress after hours
if you can
if you can wait long enough and like
it's just like that the heyday the
comedy store and now it's all [__]
preppy
it's just like it's just lame there's no
danger there anymore there was none i
still like it i think it'll come back
after all the stars left
but like man once they lock the door
once they lock that back door
because they're like liability it's like
[__] this place changed
well i'll tell you what i liked every
phase of the comedy story yeah you like
it
it's not bad it's just not as good i
like well you got to remember
again i walked out of there with my own
two feet in 2007.
i didn't crawl out nobody threw me out
nobody banned me
yeah i said one day that if i started
that
let me i'll give you a name if i started
at
royal oak comedy club what's the name of
the club and comics
doctor let's just say i started dr grins
yeah okay i start let's say i started at
uncle vinnie's
how long is my window at uncle vinnie's
from the time i get on stage
to the time i become a headline it's
about seven years
and then he's gonna tell me that then i
headline new year's i'll headline
thanksgiving i'll headline the fourth of
july i'll headline all that
yeah and after about two years of that
somebody has to come to you and say come
here ari listen
you've already overstayed your welcome
by two years
it's time to go to la and show the boys
what you got
yeah i thought about the same thing when
it came to the comedy store
when all that [__] was going down when i
could feel
i felt the tide changing the same way i
felt like
the reason why i left i felt something
wasn't right
i took myself out of there within six
minutes there was a video
rogan going off on carlos there were
other videos
other things happening there and next
thing you know
the comedy store was done i looked at it
and i go i got to give it a breather
yeah me too i had to give it a breath i
gave it a breather for
seven [__] years i didn't step foot
in there and i wasn't banned from that
no i mean i i spent about two it was the
same thing i i drove by on my way home
you know i lived like down the block
so i drove by and i was about to pull in
it was after that time where they just
like for whatever reason they decided to
ban
joe rogan for for for whatever the
[__] is but like after that mencia stuff
we were like the height of the comedy
world for about two days todd glass like
i had to run into i didn't have internet
where i was i didn't run my manager's
office when i watched that video
so for two days everybody's talking
about it and then they go we're banning
joe rogan i just felt
disgusted by it for a minute it wasn't
even a decision i just pulled in to come
in and i go
i don't want to be here and i just kept
driving went home
started going to the improv more every
time i drove by i mean i lived
like literally a block and a half away i
just felt like
look for about two years and then i was
like
i didn't feel blessed anymore and i went
in um
but you know yeah you took off longer
than i did
weird i believe even giving things a
break i believe in not letting
somebody come to you and tell you it's
time to go nobody should tell you it's
time to go you've got to tell calvary
you know what it tells cal ripken like
dude you gotta move the third we can't
thank you you're not good anymore dude
we respect you but like come on man
you already have the record i can't
believe you threw kyle ripken in that
[__]
listen i love you [__] i'm happy
you took the time to do this today man
yeah and i'll be seeing you soon
hopefully one of these nights i'll drop
in the stand at [__] tuesday and see
you
you're welcome tommy jimmy's going to
come over florentine so text him
he's going to come and see you at the
stand on a tuesday if you want to
him you were doing that the outside
patio and he said he'd go over and see
you one of the nights
yeah yeah i'll try to tell him back then
i'm happy
that you told me you feel weird on stage
because man
i felt like [__] up there and usually
when i hit the stage i feel like a new
man it's like the fountain of youth
it's fun though it's fun to be nervous
again you're like what do i say
i had my daughter i wasn't even there i
wasn't even nervous
i wasn't even nervous that's what really
got me
because i usually have a little fear
before i go on stage
i don't like that fear but that's the
fear that makes you kill on stage
i wasn't getting that fear i wasn't
getting that fear and i remembered that
take a break like you said towards the
end of
before the pandemic i was such on fire
like before the pandemic those [__]
last 90 days
i was doing the best comedy i was ever
doing in my life i was going up there
every night i was
[__] rocking i saw you at town hall
destroyed that place i was [__] on a
different level and
just you know i was in the middle of
writing new material i was writing new
material and this pandemic hit and i
don't know
listen man we change just the fact that
i haven't smoked pot in seven days
that's gotta tell you something you know
i i and i'm calling people
that i'm dear friends with and going
what could this be
and the best answer i got was dean
delray he said that maybe
my body's not that stressed out anymore
and that's one thing that is real just
getting that desperation
those people away from you that detox
from l.a
that get that [__] bugs off me i felt
so much better i'm sleeping better you
know i'm i'm just uh
i'm mentally better all around so
the right material until you're on stage
because your body doesn't make you
there's no like flight or flight so what
you got to get on there bomb
and then you're like oh [__] i need
material so it's like you can't write
until you're until you it's after you
already needed it
it's a nutty thing it's crazy that i've
been doing what paul mooney said
paul mooney always said to be a good
writer you have to be entertained at all
times
if you want to entertain you should go
get entertained
you know so i picked the news off that
was a [__]
that was a a positive during all you
know
i started playing the guitar and i
started playing the guitar and doing
lessons and
damn every time i play the guitar i feel
creative like when i start [__]
around
i don't know what i'm doing when i'm
doing the lesson
i'm uptight i'm very rigid but it's just
like stand up it's like doing material
and improvising when you're doing
material you're very rigid i found
myself very rigid on stage for a while
because you were just like you were just
like delivering lines that someone else
wrote
when somebody's like listen there was a
big difference in my
in the way i looked at comedy over the
years when i was working with rogan
and headlining on my own those stupid
clubs i didn't really give a [__]
what came out of my mouth the best
special i did
was uh the first one i don't even know
what it's called like the first one i
did with lee
because it was it's either you or the
priest
i love that special because it was
written
on the way down to breyer it was written
in the car
on the way you told me that we did and
it was the same thing where it was like
because people like how do you book
people like depends if they've proven
themselves or not you obviously prove
yourself over and over again so you told
that zoraida story and you're like all
right i don't want to tell this on stage
until i tell it on stage to record it
and i'm like
dude do whatever you want i wouldn't
allow that for most people you maybe jay
uh you know but but you're like yeah i
don't want to [__]
i don't want to go over this i want to
be on the spot and so it's like then do
it then do that and it was
[__] amazing it was amazing you were
so [__] in the moment
that was that's big for me sometimes
that's i
my problem with stand-up was i get
caught up with the material
it's not about the material it's what's
going on inside at the moment yeah
so sometimes you might write something
it's two months old now it's part of a
special
it's part of this [__] thing and it's
like it's not even you anymore
but you gotta use the special you need
the time blah blah blah blah blah blah
that's what i didn't like about comedy
like i told these people
on the podcast i go do you guys want if
you guys want
i'll just [__] charge you 40 bucks
and [__] go on the road and
go out there and talk [__] for 40
minutes even though
you're going to pay 40 for two tickets
you're going to pay for a babysitter and
dinner
i could be the biggest piece of [__] in
the world i'm a thief i've done it
before
i just go up there and sing songs i
don't give a [__] i'll do a whole
monologue on the cuban missile crisis
do you know what i'm saying i don't want
to do that i want to give them
i want to give them the best that i
could be so when i'm ready
and that pen starts [__] flowing and
i start doing little guest sets because
that's what i'm
that's how the only way i'm going to
bring myself back you got to do shows
where people don't know you
that's what separates you and a lot and
me and some other people too where it's
like it's a respect for the audience
like guys i could just go up here but
like
i'd rather just not make any money
a really good show i don't want to leave
and come to my hotel room and have
somebody on twitter go that was the
worst [__] show i've ever seen
yeah you didn't even know so that's
where i stand i love you [__]
i love you too buddy i'm on youtube now
my podcast is on youtube now finally
okay so they let you back on they left
me back on youtube
i made me promise not to have milo on
ever again we'll see
where the [__] is milo yiannopoulos he's
done he's back he's not heterosexual
he's
he's he's he said he's no longer gay and
he was a sodomite and he apologizes for
it he says it's disgusting
how the [__] do people that are gay just
stop being gay one day like that chick
from donny brasco
she was eating out ellen's [__] for
years while she was getting rolls
and then one day she's like i don't want
to do movies no more i'm going to get a
husband and get married what happened to
your [__] time as a lesbian what
happened
what the [__] you wearing a wheatload
you know you got to be a wee blob before
you get the way you're going to go
now you're not a weeblo no more what the
[__] i love you [__] stay black
i'll see you soon buddy i love you in a
few weeks okay i'll be in touch we'll
talk about that other thing too we'll
surprise these [__]
all right all right stay black happy
rosh hashanah
we got the time you got it i love you my
dad says hello
send them my love i did all right i hope
you enjoyed my little tata tay
with ari you know me i'm like [__]
sting every step i take now now you got
to be [__] careful
i hope you enjoyed this little tate
tattei with ari i had a great time
seeing him
uh don't forget if you're in new york
city jersey area
he's doing a [__] thing at the stand
every tuesday night eight o'clock
outside if you're covered [__] scared
at least you're outside
it's the spring now in new york city so
it's a fall time right now while i got
you i want to talk i want to thank our
sponsors our first sponsor as usual
is on it don't forget to go to honor.com
right now they're having their
semi-annual sale
codes do not exist their prices are so
low
that if you type in joey or church you
get dick
just go to on it right now read up on
alpha brain
shroom tech shroom tech sport shroom
tech immune
all the great products that they have
the cmt i mean they've got listen if you
don't like pills they got alpha brain
which i drink at the gym now in a
[__] powder you put it in you shake
it up you take it to the gym with you
you can drink your alpha brain
while you're at your gym that's how much
i like honey they have been with me i
have been with them for close to 10
years
i have been using their products for
close to 10 years and i like
everything they do their snack that
protein
chocolate peanut butter snack and the
coconut almond bites to 7 grams 9 grams
of protein
two more grams in an egg you know like
five grams of sugar guys if you're
asking yourself joey how'd you lose the
weight
that's my new snack at night salami has
been gone from my [__] life and she's
on white
it's just shroom tech [__] uh i do
the little bites at night if i get
hungry if i get hungry i eat an apple
i eat a protein bite so at least i get
nine grams of protein with my [__]
little midnight snack and i go nappy
nunu with the michael jackson tea but
never mind that go to honor.com right
now
preston church and go to semi-annual
sale
if you if the sale is over and you press
in church
you get 10 percent off to liberty house
it's that [__] easy
the joint is also brought to you by c
b d lion i love these [__] with
all my heart
they've even got a reefer now for cbd
so if you want to smoke it through your
lungs you could smoke it they got a bath
ball
they got a cream they got a roll-on they
got
tape cbd lion brings you cbd
from all [__] angles you understand
me they got
cbd melatonin gummies that'll put you in
[__] la la land like i am
at night i've been switching in between
them the tea you know you gotta [__]
keep yourself fresh at night
but trust me if you're having pain
anxiety
you know irritability you don't know
what the [__] going on
cbd lion go to cbdline.com and read the
third party lab results
you're gonna be [__] amazed this is
from some [__]
guy at a gas station with a [__]
birthmark on his face no no
no this is real cbd you understand me
this thing carried me through my surgery
that cream was tremendous
the tape was tremendous i mean the back
wall i go upstairs to my tub i just sit
in there for 30 minutes and soak my
[__] knee
when it comes to cbd cbd line is the
brand that you're looking for go to
cbdlion.com right now
and press in joey or church and get 20
off your order delivered to your house
they also had a huge sale recently
they also gave away a playstation 5. i
mean they're a great company
i love doing business with them i've
been there forever other people reach
out
joey could you please no i'm with cbd
lion
so like i said go to cbdline.com right
now
press in joey or church and get 20 off
and you get the cbd delivered to your
[__] house
and that's it and that's that it was
another great weekend
of uncle joey's joint i'm happy you got
to join i want to thank hari
i want to thank hannit i want to thank
zip recruit i want to thank cbd lion
don't forget there's a great ufc card
this week
[__] tremendous i will highlight it i
will be on instagram on saturday night
to give you who my picks are draftkings
as usual
code joey they'll take care of you tell
them i sent you
and without further notice i love you
[__] with all my heart
thank you for watching thank you for
being a part of uncle joey's joint
and don't forget the nfps come out
tonight patreon i love you [__]
with all my heart
stay black and have a great weekend
[Music]
you